hey man we're back what that's right I'm
back to the shooting Supergirl and flash
and me and Mark are gonna sit here and
give you oral for the next 20 minutes
this is an hour or more we'll learn how
mark learned or on today's Fatman on
Batman
man we got so much to dive into it's
been so long in a while this is so long
there's a new president coming there is
the world has changed
yeah the world has turned upside down
some people say but we're still here
damin holding it down in the fat cave
and we're got a sponsor before we dive
in give me a give me a sec before we
dive into into the news let us try to
sell you a little something sexy give
Marcos single because he's gonna tell
you about me undies yeah go to the
2-shot that's right undies like
underwear that are so nice it's like
they just hold a cup your ass for you
and me meaning you me undies as pop I
would say me and ease calm is this
service man that you sign up for and
every month they dumped a bunch of
underpants in your face have you ever
gotten a box of cotton a box of cotton
shows up in your house well that how
comes I thought they just [ __ ]
someplace through underwear at you like
Thank You mistress look I'm not that
underwear gun there's nothing to do with
a cat in just one time I went to Japan a
long time ago for Sundance 94 its Tokyo
Sunday it's Tokyo 94 and that was at a
time I don't know if they do anymore but
they used to sell like you know how you
go to the grocery store and four-quarter
used to get like gum a buck you get an
egg with something in it to [ __ ] around
with like gooey tape or whatever the
[ __ ] they had Underpants used soiled
Underpants that is not what me undies is
about man but me like a second to clap
for Japan like honestly I appreciate a
good perversion in society like anybody
I didn't see like that I thought it was
been being eco-friendly me undies calm
man they have a genius service and I
know this cuz i'm wearing their undies
right now i'd show you except i would
have to show off my lard rolls to do
that
yeah this show ain't free this gun show
if you want to see it that's good Smith
takes off his shirt like 20 minutes long
I peel we bring the cameras in and they
I eat while baby [ __ ] nook and cranny
me I would I would fear nothing after
that you know what I'm saying that's my
kryptonite so that was like a [ __ ]
pay-per-view special and sponsored by me
and he's done perhaps I would come out
of that [ __ ] fearless you know in the
whole world or the whole world like a
thousand people that signed up or
breathed that more people we're like
looking like you know it's like an asked
Werner Erhard had these seminars back in
the 70s and they would do a thing where
you'd stand there in like your just your
underwear and they would have every
member of the group come up and like
look at every pore on your body and
stuff and at first you're like this is
our fine but they said that by the end
of the exercise everybody was doing to
each other and then they're just over
that thing I would be the one that broke
that up after a hundred people like
getting all up and close to me like you
I'd be rolling tears and stuff I
wouldn't become a better person I'd
become a broken person from that
exercise you know what make me whole
again means that's right can you imagine
there's a service where you never have
to go suffer the tyranny of [ __ ]
being forced to buy underwear public
again for a large man like myself that's
humiliating man because you can't just
go into any normal story go shop with an
army shop they ain't got your selection
there and if you're like can I have a
larger size like excuse me large your
Underpants is that you're asking before
and everybody knows you know that you're
fat but me undies calm allows you to put
in whatever size you want on the down
low cutie nobody knows and every month
what do they send you they send you it
off dude this material called mow down I
want to say mow down I might be
pronouncing it wrong I'm not a the short
but they will send you a box of [ __ ]
underwear dude a box of underwear and
you know what if you dressed underwear
this is all he where - [ __ ] I mean you
could try specifying Cyril underwear I
don't think they'll send it they ain't
gonna do it man man write about the
material of them and I've won this [ __ ]
and it feels [ __ ] nice it's not cause
it's so good
space-age polymers in this fiber system
we times softer than cotton this is the
best part about Mandy's comm let's say
you sign up and you're like [ __ ] this
let's say you're outraged you're like
[ __ ] me on these [ __ ] armies and you
just want to go [ __ ] where they come
and OH
for the rest of your life somewhere
somehow someone is gonna pay the case
this is how [ __ ] cool me Andy's calm
the folks over there are they'll cancel
you out you're done you'll never hear
from them again [ __ ] oh unless you
resize up and you get to keep the
underpants this is why they don't have
our soiled Underpants business because
they would make you send it back after
you wear them and don't like him and
them off overseas yeah they're not
thinking now there's money on the table
there leave it we're gonna open up mark
undies send me your underpants me undies
month I will take your visit me undies
now how much is it cost less than two
cocktails the [ __ ] that mean all right
less than two well cocktails goldfish
bowl of tequila should say standard
cocktails included in the price is the
sweet touch of as Mark mentioned mode
modal Moodle Moodle modal mobile mode
out what would his moto is neither
villain in the Marvel Universe I've made
you know a spider-man
MODOK I was talking about that's just
three times softer than cotton so yeah
you ain't kiddin there true it does have
a weird feel to it not weird bad but
weird like this is ultra soft I know
it's like wearing cotton candy around
your privates it's like somebody blowing
gently on your balls
limited-time everyone in this audience
watchin who suffered through this
commercial because we're having a good
time they get 20% off their first order
man 20% but you have to go to the
special URL me your knees ME dot-com
slash fat man
all one word fa t ma n there you go
for those spelling challenge it's
helping you out
Reading Is Fundamental basic with me
undies better day guarantee man you down
on the loose don't wait don't wait any
longer you heard men you don't even have
to give me undies back if you don't like
them you will like them I'm wearing them
I vouch for these bucks and I feel like
a superhero Wow they've got different
designs they said any different designs
I'm wearing a pair it's got doughnuts on
them
my wife mocked me but [ __ ] her okay I
didn't get the doughnut yeah I got
ghosts
me undies dot-com slash fat man man
don't wait any long ago to me on DS
dot-com slash fat man right now for 20%
off your first [ __ ] order there's a
lot of percent I love this underwear
dude it's awesome you know really loves
it Jason Mewes o J's Muse asked me for
he's like did you get new undies those
like yeah he's gonna have it I'm like
you're not gonna fit in mine he's gonna
droop around you and [ __ ] like that
I'm making a quilt wait for your own
undies mm-hmm that's not the your own
undies calm me undies calm all right
enough about that thank you to our
sponsor me undies thank you he was
involved in this show is [ __ ] a
present okay let's hit the [ __ ] news
do it what have we missed
we missed quite a bit listen there's an
old story but let's hit this here we'll
share this no last week I was at working
on Supergirl
mhmmm show on the CB that's right I was
working on right prior to that flash
back that was like a month and a half
ago or a month ago and then I did
Supergirl right after that my flash
episode airs next week who week it's
tattoos doctor is
a week from tonight I was taping it this
coming Tuesday November 22nd 11:00 to
2:00 man 1122 my flash episode entitled
killer frost abuses whole bunch of new
images all over online there's a picture
of me with the flash and killer frost
shut the [ __ ] up dropping the mic cuz
I'm done with this [ __ ] [ __ ] life
mother just be her father what a good
time I had first time flash and then a
super [ __ ] time on Supergirl oh boy oh
boy I I had a [ __ ] blast and the both
couldn't be different more different
from each other
killer frost is like a thriller whoo
very good thriller thriller killer frost
the whole thing is like a like
aggression movie set in the world of
comics a little bit with powers and [ __ ]
I love that The CW is letting you like
indulge every genre that you possibly
could it's like I'm gonna do a sort of
relationship time-travel II romance
drama thing then a thriller then an
action movie I'm getting the exercise
different muscles like you know I've
never really told the thriller so red
states kind of through and then this
recent one the Supergirl episode we we
do like like it's very ambitious it's
different from a lot of the Supergirl up
so it's not different bad but like we
like we take a journey in journey
through time and space so it turned out
phenomenally well I was just working on
the cup this morning the first cut of
the flash is done mmm and it airs next
week Supergirl I got the first cut of
and it was 12 minutes long so I went
through an easy first pass like let's
lose this air this air and now we're
down five minutes is seven minutes left
to cut out it's gonna be tough because
like all the scenes are really good
Charm City those two kids Melissa and
Chris Wood no one else can Chris Wood he
plays mama on the show oh my god
yeah oh my god cast them and everything
they are adorable charm City man they
like their
incredible it's when I saw a trailer
today for Patriots Day the new
Peterborough she's in it like Supergirl
betrays her country she's the wife of
the older brother who ran a Boston
bombing yeah I saw her she's wearing out
what are you call a job a job and I'm
going like I want a lawyer
more truth justice in the American Way
for her you expect Alex to pop in and
any minute be like come on Cara sting or
the person who's talking to her
transforms into the marsh welcome home
he was awesome they were all awesome all
that performs all the actors on the show
cast and crew alike but David at one
point he has a line I can't [ __ ]
cants I can't say cuz they'll spoil it
but he has a line that is like so
[ __ ] DC Universe so specifically
super world mmm that's like kind of bad
you know what I can I can talk about
without spoiling he references the red
Sun of Krypton and so he has this line
where he says like he the Arcturus is a
red Sun and [ __ ] it Mike I came he said
it was so [ __ ] Pittsburgh he doesn't
David doesn't even have to be in the
Martian Manhunter persona to carry the
presence of the Martian Manhunter he is
almost more Martian Manhunter when he's
just being Hank Henshaw then when they
do they like the effects he's so amazing
he's British as [ __ ] so the moment like
he's not being Martian Manhunter he's
like so I stand of it yeah oh man her
voice hit the arms what they are is hard
I would like it though for one episode
of that was his voice bloody I'll see
you do well all you have to do is
there's an in disguise thing he's got it
they're gonna infiltrate some British
Embassy and he's got to be do it he's
not cocking in real life he's got posh
yeah he's like Savile Row that's all I
know about posh or Portobello Road
I was in broomsticks I don't at all
Bedknobs and Broomsticks can be remade
today that movie could so [ __ ] worked
day in the world where Disney's like
peach dragon and [ __ ] like that
hey off I will [ __ ] suck dick Disney
to make the remake of Bedknobs this
friend does know [ __ ] about he's not
gonna help us at all beating people
extending a staff of this Universal sign
that [ __ ] movie has a tall dude which
is battling [ __ ] Nazis with [ __ ]
ghosts in armor kids already cartoon
under the sea where they play [ __ ]
soccer do you have to drop that bit the
Isle of naboombu know you could do it
even better like it was two-dimensional
so at one point in the movie the kids
like beds bed take us to the Isle of
naboombu and the bed takes them because
they're going for the star of Astoroth
it's a long story that's [ __ ] good
something and they go under the water on
the bed and then it pops up in the
lagoon in the on the Isle of naboombu
which is all animals and clothes and
[ __ ] like that and they play a soccer
game at one point and then they steal
the King where's the star of Astoroth
he'd probably wouldn't I was gonna say
probably the soccer game but now you
would because my only liked to like
football
it was probably football back then right
we soccer to me but it was probably
making rugby so it's [ __ ] violent
this [ __ ] there you go my god because
there was that one dude the dude is
sings Portobello Road he was involved in
the game so that that's it there's a two
dimensional like animal world scene on
the olive the booboo but you could do
that as like two-dimensional animals
three dimensional CG in the jungle book
that [ __ ] you could literally juggle
hopefully that's the meeting they're
having right now in Disney man if
they're not this episode better Spurs I
would like to direct him since I won't
be allowed to I would like to thank you
invite me to the premiere you can say
that was my idea
if none of that happens I'm still
supported at the box
because a good idea is a good idea how
do we get on that I'm not Oh David in
British accent cockney boom you know who
else is amazing they're all great I had
taken away from anybody everybody's
wonderful but like Kyler's who plays
Alex supergirls sister mmm she had some
[ __ ] like she had a meaty scene on
last night's episode that had nothing to
do with like heartbreak and seeing what
you like they're doing the storyline
where Alex super girl's sister is kind
of getting involved with Maggie Sawyer
mm-hmm so she you know at first Maggie
stores like let's like I didn't know you
were gay and it's just was like oh I'm
not Kyler's like well okay Alex he's
like I'm not oh I'm not gay then she
thinks about she had a great scene a
couple weeks ago where she like sits and
talks to him so like you know what maybe
I am this week she came out to Cara and
then she like went into the bar and like
kiss Maggie and the magazine whoa whoa
like I'm not like I'm here as a friend
I'm not like into you like that I'm gay
just not gay for you pretty much and she
her [ __ ] heartbreak scene is
fantastic like she's sitting there
crying in her apartment and like super
girl comes to comfort her but it is this
is like fantastic [ __ ] acting so you
know in my episode the episode I
directed she's got some killer stuff too
but man she fun they're all fun on set
like it was fun it was such a good time
kept it light had a good time
but anyway [ __ ] what about that I was up
there in super girl world when this news
happened there's a long way to get to
the [ __ ] flash not the TV show that
I've directed twice two episodes of mmm
but the movie yes Warner Brothers DC
Universe movie stuff has lost its third
film making no yeah
second director might be third director
because the remember the kids who did
lego movie we're supposed oh that's
right yeah Miller Lord was they were the
first one in fact they're keeping their
story but they were gonna write direct
movie right then Seth grahame-smith then
Seth grahame-smith who was the guy that
did
Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter which is
a [ __ ] dope movie yeah that's what I
was like right now I'll see this flash
movie and Pride and Prejudice and
Zombies but then he left creative
differences and then the guy who did
dope in a Rik family family yeah
Saturday April I [ __ ] that up I'm sure
the dope director he was the director
and they brought him out in San Diego
age to be like I can't wait yeah it's
like it's him and it's a flaking it's
Snyder and it was patty Jenkins and like
here are our directors of your DC
Universe then he'll I was in the
audience gone remember me
Suns [ __ ] man remember I worked at in
once so close to the truth anyway the
movie flash currently has no Shepherd no
Rick left another one that said creative
differences gotta go yeah and he flashed
it out of there he's duped out of there
so currently they're without a director
all is not well in the DC Marvel DC who
who's your pick I mean you need somebody
who you know who my pick is I say come
wash house keys you think so why not I
was gonna pick the dude who did attack
the block Joe Cornish I think that's a
good poll like I think he can handle
like the humor of it he can handle the
action of it like he can bring the scale
down she that's spending a ton on it I
like his better your idea of the future
my idea of the past I mean I love those
house keys
I might fear for them is that it becomes
a bigger thing than it needs to be the
running would be amazing in the awesome
yeah fantastic but but but no no what
was that [ __ ] sexy series they're
doing Netflix ode since eight yeah they
know how to tell love Stuart to and and
that was that other [ __ ] movie they
did based on the book that nobody wants
to see but listen I thought that was
such a deeply affecting movie I thought
they did handle relationships well but
so they could do a flash I think they
could do good excellent flash but I
think your idea is [ __ ] hot what is
he working on why didn't they work why
would they like here yeah
I think he he has a writing credit on
that man because I think he was working
with Edgar Wright on it that's right
and then again Edgar might not be the
worst choice for a flash either there
you go yeah you're right is a good
[ __ ] choice for flash too they need
to get somebody for the love of Pete
yeah I mean if that train is supposed to
barrel down the road where we have all
these standalone movies that feed into
Justice League's they gotta get this
going and meanwhile poor Ezra Miller
sitting there going like the suit fits
if I start eating he's not gonna fit for
long there's a badass moment a [ __ ]
Suicide Squad when you saw him
mmm Captain Boomerang scene that's out
soon civil war is and I watched that
like couple hundred times so I'm looking
forward to diving deep diving into into
Suicide Squad cuz they're gonna have
extras right bonus like half hour 40
minutes of joke why would you want more
joker in your joker movie I want to see
just a smidge more Joker
alright man so that's flash needs a
director so if anybody out there is
looking for a job yeah anyway what's the
Tim Miller that [ __ ] call up Warner
Brothers Tim Miller
oh boy Tim Miller accidental genius
that's what you heard right here give me
a single just Tim Miller okay he's out
on the Deadpool 2 anymore so back to the
two two shot that's right let's talk
about that yeah what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] I mean let's be honest your key
ingredient in Deadpool mmm two key
ingredients I feel Ryan Reynolds yeah
and I would have said Tim Miller don't
know recently they told us that's not me
not so key at all yeah that's kind of
crazy he's going off to make a Sonic the
Hedgehog movie
mazie now that's what I read I'm gonna
leave yeah I'm pretty sure it was Sonic
bad jog which more power to him he comes
from world of games and stuff but you're
absolutely right Tim and Warner Brothers
come on come on
from the director of Deadpool that
grossed almost as much as your old
Batman V Superman movie and he think of
something he's visually [ __ ] gifted
oh yeah
some that convey running because that's
you know we've seen tastes of running
fast in the x-men movies and now in the
Avengers yeah but you got it for a whole
flash movie you gotta do something like
[ __ ] astoundingly new totally and
like the Speed Force has to be a thing
like a real thing if you could have
visualized that like oh dude who's
awesome at that and he directed one of
my favorite superhero movies ever the
pre the the previous thing for like in
the Batman game yeah where was Bruce
Wayne's face as a boy and then growing
older and then finally it was the Batman
yeah absolutely and that dude could do
justice to the flash yeah and he also
did I can't remember the [ __ ] name of
this game was but it was this big
Justice League set piece Tim I'll let
you boy College abou is we got you
we'll call it an hour Warner Brothers
[ __ ] us we'll just give you their number
and it's just a beta switch line you get
a [ __ ] idea man and what a coup for
like warm brothers and for him that
would be to be like well I'm off the
Marvel movie but hey
or it could be scooped up by real Marvel
as opposed to Fox Marvel I mean he could
be like you just play all the fields all
over the fields he can play
speaking of Marvel owned by Disney and
our shows on Netflix that are produced
by Marvel owned by Disney hmm did you
see the news that Disney's thinking
about buying Netflix I did not see that
news huh mark edits the entertainment
section at the arts section at the film
the film's second this is all crazy new
day tech no TV [ __ ] screaming he's got
nothing to do that's right mark this
film at the LA Times but today the
bridge just talking about today it's
been all over the internet that Disney's
going like we might want to buy that
which would make them the kings of
streaming content it sings of the future
remember when there was like a sort of
law against that kind of vertical
integration where you weren't supposed
to be able to own I believe the term is
called monopoly yeah because there was a
time when every movie studio also owned
all of the theaters and so they
controlled everything from soup to nuts
and that got
and made them stop doing that so this
also feels very much like that well we
are going to control both of the medium
and the message and the people who make
the medium and the message and it is
like and although for conspiracy with
first we need to see the future we're
just a squirrel trying to get him nuts
okay everything will say the same just
every third thing you've seen your cube
would be a Disney thing think about the
last two purchases they made Star Wars
and Marvel yes and then if you buy
Netflix Disney owns all of us yeah and
also let's not forget that before they
long Game of Thrones yet though no but
don't find a way to buy it but even
before that they bought Pixar that's
true yeah that's right now we just think
of Pixar as Disney but they they bought
them they [ __ ] that was their first
big move and then you know we want
everything good stock watchers watch
this Disney Company wow that's [ __ ]
nuts yeah get Netflix yeah everything I
could just deal with one company okay
robots will clean up after us and we'll
be on blind deck chairs sipping food
shakes wall-e is a dream for some of us
humans do it well give a single I were
in the Marvel World in humans who have
been sort of like not even so much as
bubbling but a main thread of the agents
of shield show on the Marvel of ABC are
getting their own television program go
back to a two-shot
that's [ __ ] that makes more sense
than doing an Inhumans movie I think so
initially when they announced phase 2
and phase 3 the Inhumans was meant to be
a movie book I mean look I'm not saying
they couldn't do it they [ __ ] took
now they've taken guardians of the
galaxy ant-man and [ __ ] Doctor
Strange and turned him into massive it's
they they are a [ __ ] golden stellar
platinum
Goldin brand yeah they can do no [ __ ]
wrong so that being said I'm sure they
would have question Inhumans movie but I
think this sounds like a dope show it
makes sense it makes sense and it's also
I mean especially kind of cult he can't
open his mouth he's the original Silent
Bob if he opens his mouth he destroys
the universe yeah I mean and it seems as
if agents of shield while I'm actually
kind of enjoying the season I'd check
back in because it goes writer mm-hmm I
did and ghost writers kind of badass is
it cool it is very cool and so I've kind
of been paying attention and watching
how the story's beginning to evolve but
they've also been threading the needle
for Inhumans yes like like all of the
last season and in the beginning of this
season it's all been about in humans and
all been about because that's the
mutants they can do they can't says they
can't say mutants so Inhumans get to be
their x-men basically so they've been
referencing on the bed but they've never
said like blackballed lockjaw they've
never done that do so but it's more like
oh here's a bunch of people who have the
inhuman gene that has been turned on and
activated and so now all these guys like
quake is it an inhuman and this guy's an
inhuman and and if shield is now an
inhuman do you think they'll do it like
the Inhumans in the comics like the
royalty and [ __ ] Saroyan they might I
mean they can totally just they can do
they can go to beautiful agents of
shield is beginning to show some radios
like the most [ __ ] real beautiful I
voted in my life
I said to my wife all the time like oh
you're so beautiful but I was just like
I heard the tear form I'm you're
beautiful I went there and the mines I
saw that jelly are teardrop only you
could make that [ __ ] but yeah like the
ratings on on agents of shield are
beginning to show some weakness a little
bits four years into a show that was
never like overwhelmingly popular to
begin with so it feels like it's taking
a little bit of a blip like it shows
that people still want a kind of show
like that right but maybe just not that
essentially though with the addition of
Ghost Rider the mess
they were set was spent more money and
they were like I guess cuz that's these
an effect right do you get the Scully on
the car yes so yeah I mean you know
that's that's spend some money and we
also don't care that much about these
characters anymore I mean a little bit
of like ghostbusters basing like the
Pucci perverse it was like we stopped
cares so much about these guys but like
it's a back door basically it could be a
bit off but it's also when in humans
like here's here's the world you will
now care about and in humans is going to
ABC yeah not Netflix is oh yeah and
they're gonna premiere the first two
episodes they can do [ __ ] when au
2017 and IMAX they're doing the first
two episodes and feeders as an event so
they can live up to their it's gonna be
a movie right look we put it in theaters
you guys know counts we had a release
date and everything come on ice cream
IMAX grant huge that's cash money
I'm in [ __ ] I like the Inhumans and
the fact that you do does a show bring
it okay
stranger things season 2 is happening
even though none of us wanted nobody
watched it it's coming back and they've
added two cast members Carter Jay Burke
Paul Reiser from aliens oh my god you
went with his aliens I was sitting there
going yeah Carter Burke and when it went
bad Ripley but sometimes you gotta make
the call he's just a grunt you can't ask
him to make that kind of decision the
greatest performances of all time it
really is imagine how [ __ ] good you
have to be a good job to outshine a kid
who was brilliant
horny Weaver was brilliant yep all the
direction by camera which was brilliant
the [ __ ] not one alien but a
gazillion aliens what
which is brilliant and then a [ __ ]
Queen alien which was even more
brilliant and we're sitting still like
when people talk about the movie
whenever I talk about it my one of my
first thoughts is watch butter sure
these performances [ __ ] pitch perfect
you know right what's his last name
Hudson I'm Hudson okay so Paul Rizer
Paul Reiser man who was brilliant in
that movie ten Samwise Gamgee was a bad
call Ripley it was a bad call and then
who Samwise Gamgee from the Lord of the
Rings movies Sean Astin estimates it's
gonna be in stranger things I know
they're basically giving you all of the
80s at once
oh he's a goonie he's a goodie I forgot
all I could think of I was like why do
they want to Lord of the Rings I was
like the arts but he's a [ __ ] o OG
goony for crisis gue oh that is a good
catch
yeah [ __ ] stranger things took me a
minute to catch up wow it's a
Renaissance of early acid it really is
no so that we're all gonna fall down the
[ __ ] once again thank you I coined
that phrase just in case it takes off
all right stranger things that goes into
- members they're doing it let's say you
know what man
okay that's a lot of news let's break it
up break it up we have like there's a
[ __ ] ton more that we got to get to so
[ __ ] yeah let's put a pin in it Boop and
come back in two [ __ ] days can't wait
that long
come on [ __ ] addict
holy [ __ ] all right that's all job come
back in the next episode here is a
preview you when we talk about the
Harlequin movie yes where you talk about
Green Hornet are you talking about bunch
of [ __ ] yeah pretty nice for fact now
about now I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard comeback you know [ __ ] next
time same bat-time same bat-channel
Mod cast calm or youtube.com/ period
Kevin Smith you think I'd remember that
it's my job
you